énorme c'est le qualificatif qu'on
pourrait donner à la tâche qui attend
joe biden fraîchement intronisé 46e
président d'un pays dont l'économie est
complètement plombé rien que la première
semaine de janvier le nombre des
demandes d'allocations chômage a encore
augmenté 281 milles la plus forte hausse
depuis le début de la pandémie
c'est notamment les secteurs du loisir
ou de l'hôtellerie qui sont les plus en
difficulté avec près de 500 mille
emplois supprimés au mois de décembre et
ce n'est sans doute pas la fin du
cauchemar pour corriger le tir
by donne à dégainer il ya un mois un
plan de sauvetage de 900 milliards
validé par le congrès américain
600 dollars ont été versés aux ménages
modestes et plus de 4 millions de
chômeurs au vu leur couverture prolongée
et ce n'était qu'un acompte puisqu'en
janvier c'est carrément un nouveau plan
à 1900 milliards qui a été annoncé par
le nouveau président avec cette fois des
chèques de 1400 dollars versés aux
américains en fonction de leurs revenus
une vraie avalanche de billet vert à
laquelle bill donne pourrait encore
rajouter d'autres mesures et donc
d'autres milliards comme il doubler le
salaire minimum le maintien coûte que
coûte des emplois publics du pays où un
nouveau programme national de
vaccination
après les marchés soutenus et whatever
it takes par la fed
c'est donc maintenant toute l'économie
américaine qui se retrouve sous
perfusion
[Musique]